your secrets it's been reported but we
don't know the specifics but just real
quick I was
oh
that's on the other side of my pants I
like to be as surprised as you all are
yeah we'll be we're definitely surprised
ABC's hit talker The View had some extra
sound effects during Wednesday's live
show
say that again yep it sounds like one of
the co-hosts let went loose in the
middle of their discussion specifics but
just real quick halting everything and
causing some Giggles it all started when
Whoopi pointed out a puddle to co-host
Sarah Haynes and she reacts to the
mysterious leak by shifting in her chair
and then the fart noise is her specifics
but just real quick I was oh we had a
little silage on the other side of my
pants but this isn't the first time
someone has seemingly passed gas on the
talk show I can't tell you anything it's
okay Whoopi it's been years since 2011's
incident yeah
thank you
oh excuse me
that just blew a little frog out of
there
and time has passed since 2014's fart
gate I want to inject something into my
skin that's gonna excuse me
don't read Twitter don't read Facebook
because they will go after you for
anything that you say and you have to
develop a tough skin against that the
internet insisted whoopee was the
culprit behind the fart it was an out of
body experience but she defended herself
the next day saying she doesn't fart on
air for real it's going to be us trying
to not
implode on the show and and just helping
people figure out the things that maybe
there have questions about so thanks for
clarifying and helping us figure things
out Whoopi if you can't handle a fart
you can't handle me
[Music]
thank you